this is always very difficult and in my
opinion it starts with the chief
executive officer it's very important
for a chief executive officer to have a
sense of strategy when it comes to
change and then personally become
committed to that change process I'll
give you an example of a company that I
was involved with Wyatt in my old days
this company had missed some
opportunities when the biotech
revolution occurred and I was asked to
by the chief executive officer at that
time I was running a major division to
see if Wyatt could be more active in
biotechnology and make up for some lost
time we were successful in making an
acquisition of a company in Cambridge
Massachusetts called genetics Institute
one of the smartest things that we did
was to buy only about sixty percent of
that company and leave the biotech
culture intact give them the financial
strength give them some managerial tools
that existed in the company but but
basically let them run the company about
five and a half years later the back end
the forty percent was bought out and the
company was made a part of Wyatt that
period of leaving them separate and
nurturing them and letting them grow and
finish the innovations was enormously
important had we brought that operation
in a smashed it in with the older
businesses it would never have had a
chance to grow and and and and and
become big now when we read about the
one of the biggest reasons why Pfizer
made the purchase of Wyatt is the
biotechnology insights why you can see
the enormous value that got unleashed by
accessing a new revolution but keeping
it somewhat separate during its early
years
is a very important question because all
big enterprises in order to grow and
prosper have to be global most parts of
the world outside the US are growing
faster than the US economy and a global
organization can grow outside the US
faster than inside the US my company
schering-plough grew to a level where
seventy percent of the business was
outside the US I think it's a great
opportunity the key to success in my
opinion is to have a network of country
managers who are absolute a players and
it's also important just like the
president gets to see ambassadors when
they sent to other countries is CEOs I
as a CEO got to see every country
manager before they were appointed a
country manager and we insisted that
country managers not only had to be a
players in terms of being insiders and
driving the business in their own
countries but also to be a member of the
global network of country managers and
also to be ambassadors of the center so
they don't try to become local barons or
local chiefs trying to fight off the
center or to fight the other countries
in terms of being well recognized and
and in terms of the competition that can
naturally develop among country managers
we created a culture that fostered a
team spirit but we also looked for
individuals that had their attitude to
be a part of the global whole once that
occurs once you can get strong people on
the ground who have this broad view of
things then the center in build value to
the car at the country level and the
country can build value in the center
because communications become more fluid
and more part of the team also one
country can build value in another
country because that creates a more
fluid dynamic
one way we encourage such a culture was
to align the incentive system of the
country managers the people in the
center and the senior management to be
such that they'd be a much easier
sharing of information and a sharing of
objectives
I think the new workers have to have a
very different attitude from workers 20
years ago and more importantly 50 years
ago there is a lot of change now
compared to the past so what one carries
with oneself throughout one's career is
one's own attitude and a desire to learn
and to grow and so I would say to those
who are coming into the world of
business today number one always work
hard to be in tune in tune with oneself
no one's own capabilities and
requirements and and growth plans being
be in tune with the environment because
that's that's always going to change be
in tune with the colleagues because the
importance of human relationships has
not changed even as other things have
changed and having colleagues that would
support you and your work will make you
a lot more effective than having
colleagues who are not well connected
with you be in tune with the bosses
because they can mentor you guide you
teach you be very much in tune with
those who supervise because they have to
look to you as their natural leader you
that that natural leadership status is
earned it's not given to you just
because you're above the other people on
the old chart the other aspect is to
constantly see life as a journey and to
understand that journey has twists and
turns and it's always good to be
opportunistic and to learn and grow but
then to have an even better attitude
when unexpected difficulties arise and
they will always arise in anybody's
journey and to be able to lift oneself
up and keep going is a very important
aspect of how well people handle change
and to be able to retrain oneself to
reinvent myself as the environment
changes is also very important
I think the difficulties are rising even
before people get to college we have too
many people in our society to too many
children or young adults who are
dropping out and in some community the
dropout rates are terrible it's just not
okay we've got to do something about
that so we have to deal with the issues
in the schools encourage an environment
of learning encourage an environment of
accountability especially among the
teachers and encourage an environment of
some more parental responsibility even
though we recognize that that's not easy
once children once people come into
college we have to create the right
environment for people to learn skills
just learning some simple concepts in
history or geography might be great but
they may not prepare oneself for the
business world so basics of health
literacy career literacy financial
literacy these are basic tools that
people should be taught everybody should
be taught that because these are life
management tools they're not taught as
well as they are as they should be
taught also I personally believe in
apprenticeships it's a good a good way
for people to get engaged to get the
hands dirty to learn to be tested to to
be examined by future employers as as
people who could do a good job there an
apprenticeship is a good idea because
employers are more willing to
participate in those programs so few
children fewer college graduates are
left unemployed so something like that
is a great they should be incentives for
companies to give apprenticeships so
that young people get a chance to to see
what the world of business looks like
and then having good mentors and so one
can always go back and check with people
about their progress and how they could
plan them their various moves in life
that's that's very important good
network of colleagues who who they can
talk to is
so very for